ils sont arrivés la semaine dernière
mais se sentent déjà comme chez eux dans
cet ancien hôtel de buc transformée en
établissement de co living une dizaine
de jeunes et professionnels en
déplacement se partagent désormais
l'espace j'ai non seulement pour six
mois
c'était assez idéale de se dire qu'on
puisse arriver avec sa valise se pose et
repartir quand on veut et par le même
biais de pouvoir faire des connaissances
à des amis avoir un peu de la vie autour
de nous c'est plus l'idée de rencontrer
des jeunes comment jeunes débutants et
aussi des amis trois étages aménagé en
vingt-et-une chambre pour les occupants
avec cuisine salle à manger est un
espace comores king pour christophe
dulong propriétaire des lieux cette
reconversion est le fruit d'une
évolution sociétale avec les nouveaux
modes de fonctionnement qui sont
actuelle mais qui vont perdurer
il y aurait moins de déplacements moins
de déplacements par les - de formation
beaucoup plus de choses qui se font en
télétravail ou en formation à distance
et donc les déplacements d'affaires mon
avis vont souffrir
une entreprise spécialisée en caux
living a été engagé à la campagne les
investisseurs autour des travaux à
réaliser jusqu'à la gestion des
locataires on est quand même sur des
gens qui qui sont presque des jeunes
actifs qui sont pas forcément de la
région rennaise qui viennent dans des
régions où ils déménagent pour
pour des raisons presque un
professionnel et donc du coup c'est les
aider à s'intégrer rentrée du monde à
l'offre aussi la leur offrir aussi un
espace confortable et une démarche aussi
simplifié dans la partie administrative
c'est le plus gros espaces gérés par la
société
bien que ce mode de colocation xxl soit
de plus en plus courant pour les loyers
ils vont de 680 euros par mois à 800
euros pour les grandes suites avec salle
de bains toilettes et kitchenette